hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from the London chest
classic feel a open it's pregnant versus
room usar French Grand Master who last
year won the 2018 London chest classic
v-day open so definitely one of the
favourites to win the tournament
and it's a game from round seven so far
Prabhu hasn't lost a single game and we
I thought of covering it sooner but we
were kind of busy covering the the
Grantchester final solo and we were only
covering it now so without further ado
let's enjoy the game probably with the
white pieces opens with E 4 we have c5
by moose our Knight to f3 d6 and Bishop
to b5 check the canal attack we have
Bishop to d7
Bishop characters Knight captures and
castles we have 90 to f6 and now quinta
e - like Carlsen played against the Giri
in the type of steel blitz edition in
India we have rooked c8 by moose our and
now c3 preparing d4 with east 6 and now
d for us ok C captures we have C
captures and d5 now now it's you know
it's the dream when you're able to
execute d5 in the Sicilian but here our
black gets into some developing problems
as Knight to e4 is definitely playable
here and it is what is being played
today for for those who play this line
but here black prefers a knight the g8
the idea is that ok now you pushed ePHI
will no longer have control of f5 so
here black wants the riemann over the
Knight to f5 via e 7 so okay we have
Knight to c3
Bravo continuous development Knight to
the e7 and now there are games were
Bishop to g5 and the rook to e1 were
played but Age 4 is a new move by
progress so as a move 12 we have a
completely new game night the 5 black
continues rima new ring the knight now
you have to develop the bishop perhaps
Castle kingside
Bishop to g5 now attacking the Queen and
Bishop to e7 are hoping to trade bishops
and now Queen to d3 most likely with the
idea that if Bishop captures you can
capture with the knight and the Queen
will still be controlling the d4 pawn
also maybe if the knight moves you you
do have access to b5 but that's maybe
for some later parts of the game we have
g6 by moose are and now Queen to d2
now again you will you used to control
the the d4 square but now you can also
perhaps play something like Bishop to h6
with h6 Bible a6 by black and now rook 8
the c1 continuing development look the
c6 and now comes Knight to e2 offering a
trade of rooks a g4 here is the critical
continuation where if you move the
knight then you can get something like
Bishop to h6 it's a very strong idea and
if black castles then you can bust open
with h5 so here we would see Bishop
captures H captures and now finally
after the knight moves you get King to
g2 with the idea that you want to play
rook each one looks the h6 and then
bring the other look over to h1 and have
a lot of pressure along the H file what
produces a different continuation he
goes Knight to e2 now offers the rook
trade and now Knight the b8 black wants
to be able to recapture with the night
so to have even more pressure on the d4
pawn and here progress sacrifices upon
with b4 he wants to play a 4 and B and
b5
so Knight captures on age 4 black
grabbed to the pawn Bishop captures with
Bishop characters and now just a for
continuing to develop pawns on the Queen
side we have Bishop the back T 7 so it's
not a target on h4 that you don't want
to have Queen to h6 with an attack on
the bishop here so b5 and now say what
you will black is up upon but his King
is still in the center of the board we
have 8 captures a captures the rook is
under attack rook captures in c1 and the
rook a person c1 and here black really
has to make a difficult decision
how will he continue this game and the
critical continuation is will he Castle
or or not point is if he castles what
he's probably afraid of Queen to c2 and
the infiltration on the Queen side here
the b7 pawn is weak but point is you
will be
to wiggle out after Queen to e8 you
attack the pawn queen to c7 now saying
okay you grab the point I'll grab the
bishop and now you play Bishop to e3 you
attack the rook so why White has no time
to grab the pawn rook b1 now defending
the b5 form and now Queen to d7 offering
a trade while also defending the b7 pawn
now you go back when a5 Bishop goes back
to e 7 and here black was able to safely
castle and also saved b7 pawn so this
was the critical line for black however
black decides to go for King to d7 it's
an unusual move but basically you want
to develop the black Queen somewhere
bring the rook over to d8 and then
castle artificially with King to e8 so
here so if you continue with something
like Queen to c2 it's not a problem
because you can always go Queen to a5
and then out bring the roof to d8 and
hide the King away so after King to b7
we have Queen to f4 now by Praga going
after the week's f7 pawn on the Kings
side look the FA defending and now
Knight to c3 the night and now defense
the pawn here also prepares to go night
a4 to c5 on c5 the night will be an
excellent piece of black wants to get
rid of it he will have to give up the
bishop and then he will even improve
White's pawn structure on the Queen side
but also there are some very interesting
tricks with Knight captures on d5 for
example if black were to prevent Knight
a 4 by going Queen to a5 now you just
sacrifice the night here pawn captures
and now you go queen g4 check and now
the Queen and rook nicely connect on c8
so here you move the King Queen checks
and now you don't really have any any
good moves here if you block with the
bishop you just pick up the night if you
block with the Queen to save the knight
you just pick up on b7 and now rook the
c8 adjust wins the game in black will
lose the Queen so there's no way around
this so here black has to wait and see
what white will do so h5 and now Prager
goes for Knight to a4 so ok there's no
danger of knife captors and d5 anymore
so black goes Queen to a5 but now Prager
just goes Knight the c5 with check we
have Bishop captures and ok now you
cannot recapture with the pond since you
lose the b5 point but you have rook
captures on c5 and
here we have v6 pushing this rook away
and here again Prabhu has to decide it's
okay just to move back the rook because
black will have some serious problems if
he goes for the pawn if he goes for the
pond then you get Knight the g5 with
some very nice threats of just Knight
captures on e6 for example if black
plays whatever you will capture on e6
and now you cannot capture here because
you lose the rook and if you capture
with the King it's just checking the
servant checking moves wherever you just
capture with the rook and now there are
a lot of ways you can win this game
white will be completely winning here so
after b6 Praga doesn't go for Rupe to c1
first he goes Queen to h6 says okay you
capture this rook I'll capture this rook
and then I'll capture the f7 pawn and
win the game this way we have looked
eight black says no thank you and now
only now Prager goes back with rook to
c1 we have Queen captures on b5 without
capturing this pawn black can't really
hope to achieve anything so blacks only
chance is to get rid of this pawn and
then I try to consolidate Bravo goes up
here Queen to g7 now puts pressure on
the f7 pawn and now it's difficult well
it's impossible to guard the point
because if rook to e7 just Queen to f8
you threaten checkmate with Queen to c8
and now if you repeat the rook to e8
adjust Queen to d6 is made so there are
a lot of ways for black to go wrong here
on the other hand if King to e7 you you
defended then you just go Knight to the
8 4 and now Knight captures and g6 is
coming rook to c7 you can also
infiltrate with that again a completely
winning for white so after Queen g7
black decides for Knight to c6 gives up
the f7 pawn with check so Queen captures
on f7 rook to e7 and now Queen to f8
again putting a lot of strain on blacks
position if you move the Knight Queen to
c8 check will again be mate so here we
have Queen to a4 by black putting
pressure on the d4 pawn although like I
said it cannot be played once you
capture with the night Queen to see it
is just made so here we have Knight the
h4 by white going after the g6 pawn now
and now Queen a3 attacking the rook here
but also
putting the Queen on the same diagonal
as the wife Queen for the moment you
cannot use this since there's no way for
like to deliver check with the rook and
then pick up the Queen ah
but still you should always be careful
so here we have rook to be one attacking
the b6 pawn kink the c7 and now comes
Knight captures on g6 here it seems like
probably under the piece because black
plate Queen to d3 now attacking the
knight and the rook can be one but
Prague has it all figured out so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find the best way how to get out of this
messy situation while I give you a
couple of seconds for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations on
finding the best way to get out of this
mess and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it's a rope to see one
point is now if the knight is captured
you just capture the rook with check
since the the knight is pinned I'm sure
you all found that so congratulations
so black after Luke the c1 decided for
rook to d7 just got the rock out of the
way but now once again there is D there
is a one a one of the easiest way to end
this game so once again feel free to
pause the video and now try to find the
best move for white that just wins on
the spot well I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who are able
to do it congratulations on helping
Prague win the London chest classic
fidei open and for those who just want
to enjoy a show it's nice to be 7 like
we said the rook cannot capture because
just win captures the knight is pinned
you will not be able to recapture and
there is no move there is no defense
against rook captures on c6 it's just
Wednesday night and then his game over
black is just getting made so it was a
unmov'd 38 that usual moose are resigned
the game and problem not only won this
game but he also want the tournament
without losing a single single game I do
have the standings here well part of the
standings but just so you can get a get
a glimpse of progress results here you
have it Prague or one
well shared first but to do to better
tie breaks he took first place with 7
and a half out of 9 same as rule moosari
genres are wanted in 2018 with 7 and a
half hour 9 and here
see he won fourth place with seven out
of nine so this was definitely an
important game for both of them but yeah
out of 166 players
Prague won the prague who won who won
the tournament well a shirt purse with
anton smirnov but again any an
incredible result without losing a
single game so not only this problem win
the tournament but he also crossed 2600
in live ratings which if he doesn't lose
any games until January in classical
time format he will be out as a 2600
Grandmaster which is incredible as he
still only 14 years old well barely 14
he turned 14 in August so incredible
stuff and well we can only imagine what
Prague will achieve in 2020 in the
beginning of the year he won the
extremely strong extra Khan open in
Denmark then he won the World Youth
Championship now he crossed 2600 and now
he won for the you know just to wrap up
the year nicely the London chest classic
feat a open so incredible stuff from
young Prabhu and like I said we can only
wait and see what he will achieve in
2020
so yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it a lot of you were requesting
this so sorry you had to wait for so
long I would like to thank 11/8 Pro
Cupid's Armin Fabian Donald Mathewson
Jeff jolly and Kenneth McKay of Scotland
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check too on my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions I don't know if we'll be
covering any more games from the
Grantchester I will have to check and
after all is said and done we will start
with our big new saga which is of course
the Paul Morphy saga as the majority of
you have voted for that saga so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day